action bienvenue dans les coulisses du
tournage d'un film à petite échelle
caméraman ingénieur son script et
réalisateur l'équipe de techniciens sur
le second court métrage de tony chasse
lass est quasiment au complet
quand je suis toujours quand la setil
âge est effectivement le bruit de la
scène qui tombe normalement c'est un
briquet sont fait entendre ça aurait dû
être méticuleux le réalisateur fait le
coin avec son équipe avant de tourner
une scène dans la mise en production
d'un film chaque poste a un rôle bien
précis et son importance cela permet de
ne rien laisser au hasard
je suis assistante real c'est à dire que
je suis un peu le chef d'orchestre
j'organise c'est moi qui organisais le
tournage à la préparation j'ai fait le
planning par exemple pour cette seconde
réalisation tony chasse classe a
souhaité réunir une partie de l'équipe
de son premier film là je joue deux
méchants dans le projet d'avant et dans
celui là qui sont opposés deux mois en
fait et donc j'aime j'aime tout être
quelqu'un d'autre en fait le financement
d'un court métrage est souvent une tâche
délicate si pour son premier film tony
chasse là ce avait fait appel au
cruising il a entièrement autofinancé le
second avec un budget estimé à 1500
euros
cela explique l'équipe réduite autour du
projet le film en fait comme le casting
il est pas très très grand et qu'on
travaille à l'intérieur on a besoin on a
besoin d'un peu moins de monde donc du
coup ça permet d'avoir des personnes
dédiée plutôt concentré de talent le
film intitulé certes ruem meurtre en
verlan devrait être disponible sur
internet début 2018